Dragon Age Inquisition is out this week
which means I get to return to fetus one
of my favorite fantasy gaming world's
high fantasy games allow all kinds of
weed and wonderful game locations and
here a five of the very best first up is
a relatively small game world compared
to the rest of my selections but it was
one of my earliest favorites bioshock's
rapture the introduction to the
underwater acts utopia current dystopia
was one of my most memorable gaming
experiences with its distinct 1950s Art
Deco architecture the city of tunnels
and chambers at the bottom of the sea
created with the ideals of freedom and
capitalism felt totally new and unique
to video games anyway Bioshock made you
feel like rapture with an entire society
with economics research facilities
political dissonance and a history you
really need to delve into for yourself
just don't let the splicers get you okay
so this one's pretty enormous but it's
still totally worth mentioning the
continent of Tamriel in the Elder
Scrolls series each Elder Scrolls game
takes on a new province from Daggerfall
to morrowind to skyrim among others
the most compelling feature of this
fictional world is that skyrim isn't
just that bit of Tamriel to the north
nor is Sara dill defined only by its
oblivion gates and imperial city there's
so much intricate detail here each
province is packed full of individual
cities that have their own customs
cultures environment stories and
inhabitants that are totally independent
of one another with an open-world
landscape that adapts with every step
you take and new characters and quests
behind every doorway there are few game
worlds that feel as alive as Tamriel
if we're praising game world's for being
huge and full of life then it's
impossible to disregard the world of
warcraft itself Azeroth you don't need
to play World of Warcraft for very long
to notice that being in Azeroth really
feels like being somewhere brand-new and
thriving the world is full of enemies
NPCs and other players which keeps you
engaged in the universe Azeroth is home
to dozens of BC's Easter eggs for the
curious epic skyboxes and carefully
fashioned environmental design that
makes each area feel noticeably
different given that it's an MMO World
of Warcraft has a constantly evolving
world where players form connections to
certain locations as a result of their
experiences the Cataclysm expansion
decimated the original Azeroth by
changing much of the geographical
landscape permanently from the crowded
wild jungles of stranglethorn to the
mysteries of the Haunted tower cars on
adventuring to the far corners of
Azeroth feels epic number two on my
countdown is a personal favorite of mine
if the many colors' realms monsters and
metaphors of Wonderland in Alice madness
Returns American McGee kicked off his
twisted take on Alice's story in 2000
but the technical and graphical advances
between then and madness Returns 11
years later made the sequel into a
smattering of makar visual delights
given the world resides only in Alice's
warped mind the art directors and
designers had full rein to unleash
whatever they could dream up what
resulted was a dark and twisted fantasy
Wonderland Alice begins in the
traditional Wonderland of the veil of
Tears or veil of Doom once it's
distorted and mangled
she then ventures through the fiery
Hatter's domain under the sea to the
diluted depths into the eastern inspired
oriental Grove complete with samurai
wasps and to the doll house packed with
abandoned and occasionally vicious toys
it's not technically part of the visual
world but madness Returns is
in with an atmospheric and grim
soundtrack that complements the many
environments you encounter Alice's
imagination is a vivid dangerous and
beautiful thing to watch unravel much
like the realms within it and my number
one pick is the game I think most
effectively generates that feeling of
being transported to a whole new world
it's none other than Hyrule in ocarina
of time hyrule makes you feel like a
tiny fish in a huge and complicated pond
full of mysteries to uncover and bushes
packed with rupees to exploit you get a
proper sense for the size of Hyrule by
walking or if you're lucky riding
through it the distinct realms contain
different races with specific problems
for link to solve chucking kaku's about
getting married to a fish girl in zora's
domain and playing a gowron's favorite
song on death mountain all factored in
there somewhere much like Alice it's not
simply the beauty of the world but the
accompanying soundtrack that makes this
fantasy world so exceptional the
interplay between strong atmosphere
creative environmental design and music
can do so much to the effectiveness of a
game world let me know in the comments
which fantasy game world is your
favorite and I'll catch you next week
you